[Music]
here we are
together we're on an
adventure seeing what else life has to
offer is that a little scary sure but
isn't it worth
it we're not going to make it are we
Uncle
Dan what is this place we are completely
lost was your mother
that is not your mother looking at it
now we're trying to get to Jamaica it
all seems so
simple don't worry Chum's gotcha so
listen Chum what did you just call me
sorry I thought your name was chump yeah
chump yeah that's my name what right so
listen chump what did you just call me
I'm sorry is everyone else hearing
chump
what
this isn't about migration it's about
Adventure wo wo wo wo
hey what just happened I don't know but
you're in
trouble what is that dange what's
dange it's you with Lan on
top there's a whole world we've been
missing out on and we well
a when danger
strikes you do not run from it
reload we're going to finish this
crazy wonderful
Adventure so
adorable maybe I'll eat you I'm
kidding where am
I
huh go go
[Music]
[Applause]
go